so in the last video we were talking
about the system of labor in the
chesapeake area
surrounding the chesapeake bay in the
early english colonies in america and
one thing that seemed a little bit
strange there was that even though the
first ship
with enslaved africans
arrived in virginia
in 1619
slavery wasn't actually the dominant
form of labor in virginia until much
later in the late 1600s
in fact the vast majority of laborers in
virginia were in fact white indentured
servants
and these indentured servants
would come from england and
the
planter that they proposed to work for
would pay their passage
across the atlantic
and in exchange the servant would agree
to work for that planter for a period of
three to seven years and this is an
example of what one of these indentures
might have looked like uh it's in old
timey writing so it's a little hard to
see but here you can see that there's
three years is the amount of time that
this person promises and this is from
pennsylvania kind of gives you a good
sense of how someone would say all right
i'm going to work for this person for
this long in exchange for my passage
and it's a contract and this was a
pretty good deal
for planters because for every person
that they brought over from england they
got another 50 acres of land meaning
that if you had the money to bring over
quite a few servants you could expand
your land holdings very fast and the
other good thing about this at least in
in terms of the planters was that these
indentured servants uh had a pretty high
rate of death it was not healthy to live
in this swampy area of virginia so quite
frequently planters didn't actually have
to make good on their promise to set
these indentured servants up with some
land of their own some tools to work it
because they didn't survive through
their indenture so if this system of
indentured servitude and the head right
system that gave planters more land for
bringing over more servants was working
out so well for them why did african
slavery become the dominant form of
labor
in virginia starting about
1700.
you know when we we think about tobacco
cultivation and later cotton cultivation
in the american south before the civil
war what we think of is enslaved african
laborers and indeed by the year 1700
about 15 percent of the population
living in virginia was enslaved africans
going from just a handful at the
beginning of the century so what caused
this incredible transition in not only
labor but also racism to happen in early
america well there's one major event
that historians tend to point to as a
turning point in american slavery and
that is the rebellion led by nathaniel
bacon in 1676
so let's talk a little bit more about
that
so to understand bacon's rebellion we
have to backtrack a little bit and talk
about the development of political power
and tobacco in virginia so in 1619 the
virginia company established the first
government in virginia it was called the
house of burgesses
and this is really important because
it is in effect the first at least
semi-democratic
form of government in the new world
i mean in a way it's kind of like a
parliament that was set up for virginia
so that they could debate local issues
and it's going to be the house of
burgesses and its later virginia house
of delegates that ends up leading the
charge for the american revolution more
than a century later than this but as we
think about the way that political power
was distributed in virginia you can
guess who might have a lot of say in the
house of burgesses and these are the
tobacco planters
so the government of virginia
although it is a democracy of these
land-owning men is still got most of the
power at the very top because as we
talked about in the last video the power
system in virginia looked like
a handful of planters at the top
a very small number of
free
white
farmers
who had their own land but nothing like
the gigantic tracts of tobacco
plantations that the planters had then a
whole lot of white indentured servants
who have very little political power
since they are
at basically the mercy of the planters
and then just a tiny handful of
black slaves
and in this time period you know white
indentured servants and black slaves
black free people
also a tiny number
didn't have that much difference when it
came to political rights in fact white
indentured servants frequently
complained that they felt that slaves
were treated better than them which may
have been the case because they were
worth more remember they were worth
hundreds of pounds whereas white
indentured servants cost just a couple
of pounds to come over frequently died
so they were less of an investment than
slaves the other important factor here
is just what it takes to grow tobacco
tobacco is a labor-intensive crop we
know but it's also kind of a crop that
is extremely hard
on the soil it depletes the soil fast
which means that there is a constant
need for new soil and when you're coming
from the coast here's our atlantic ocean
over here
this is virginia
and our jamestown colony along
the river james more and more
planters as they come over
uh remember we have this head right
system we have a system that says that
if indentured servants finish out the
terms of their indenture they get land
of their own means there is constant
pressure
to add more and more land so you can
farm more and more tobacco
you start going farther and farther into
the interior so what does this mean it
means that land becomes relatively
scarce pretty fast and it also means
that
as white settlers continue to move west
toward the appalachian mountains which
are over here i hope you enjoy this
beautiful map
certainly a work of art
they are running up against more and
more anger and conflict
with native americans who are living in
between the coast and the appalachian
mountains
and now it's definitely in the interest
of
the house of burgesses the government
here at jamestown to make sure that
there's as little conflict with native
americans as possible remember we had
these wars of extinction with the
powhatans that wasn't a fun time for
anyone and so the house of burgesses
which is now somewhat responsible to the
king of england uh since he acquired it
from the virginia company as a royal
colony in 1624 they have a relatively
friendly attitude toward the native
americans they're hoping to avoid
conflict and so their governor
governor william barkley
spelled berkeley but pronounced barkley
i don't know why he refuses to take uh
on another war of extinction against the
native americans which makes a lot of
white servants and white freemen pretty
angry it's the late 1600s now and
more and more of these indentured
servants are living to finish out their
terms of indenture they've now built up
some immunity to these diseases that
have killed so many other people in
virginia and they're finding it really
hard to make a living because the
planters don't want to give quite so
many rights quite so many perks to
people who live out there in dentures
remember this was a this was a good deal
for planters when these white servants
never actually survived to make good on
the promises of land and
now that they are planters don't want to
extend them things like a promise of
land because land is already scarce so
when servants are finishing up their
indentures they're finding it difficult
to make a living they often have to
continue to work for
the planter they had been indentured to
for very small wages they don't have
land of their own they can't get started
and this is a world composed almost
entirely of men so they can't even find
women to marry and i think if there's
anything we've learned from us history
it's that you never want a whole lot of
unemployed angry young men hanging about
because young men with a lot of time on
their hands get up to trouble and one
young man in particular was this fellow
here nathaniel bacon
who was incensed
at governor barkley's refusal to take a
harsher stance against the native
americans on the west where all of these
white farmers wish that they could
settle and so he gets up a militia
full
of young white men and also
african-american men to actually go
after the native americans so this is a
biracial
raid force for native americans and they
raid native american villages and
kill many native americans living in the
area and governor barkley wants them to
stop and instead of stopping they
marched to jamestown the capital of
virginia and set it on fire
so this is a group of
landless
white men landless african-american men
who have rebelled against the government
of virginia these are my my flames a
house of burgesses they run barkley out
of town
and it's hard to know where this would
have ended because nathaniel bacon
himself died
and he died of illness
like many other virginians in this time
period so the rebellion kind of petered
out without his leadership but clearly
this is a really scary moment for the
house of burgesses and for the leaders
and planters in virginia and they
started to think all right well maybe
this indentured servitude thing isn't
working out so well because once these
indentures are up we've got this whole
set of landless free whites who
technically have the rights of
englishmen but we have little work for
them we have little land for them and
it's going to end up with constant
rebellion so maybe we should think about
a different source of labor one that
will never get its freedom and it just
so happened that there were many such
laborers for sale on the coast of west
africa and we'll talk more about that in
the next video